all right let's bring in now mark though
in beirut he's a former candidate for
the lebanese parliament good to have you
with us so
let's start with the obvious elephant in
the room who on earth was keeping
this much ammonium nitrate in a
warehouse at a port
uh basically someone was trying to
import that material in 2014 which is
not allowed and then
there was they impounded the material
and
there was a court case running for the
past six years which obviously
only extended this far and wasn't
directly re-exported
because of political pressure and
interventions with the justice system
another side of the corruption that
dominates lebanon and has led to the
systematic
breakdown of the state and the failure
of so many functions including economic
including we already had a crisis with
garbage piling up
and now with that explosion yesterday it
trained glass
in beirut everyone's home is damaged in
a radius
of four to five kilometers people's
lives are completely damaged not to
mention the corona
right right yeah we'll get to the damage
in a moment but
the thing that's perhaps interesting one
of the many things
sadly interesting here is what when you
say
because of corruption it was left in the
port
everybody knows that the ports the
airport are controlled
by armed factions in that country
there must have been some level of
decision-making amongst the political
and military factions to keep that
amount of ammonium nitrate there right
this wasn't just like an administrative
oversight
yes it's not a pile of small
combustibles that you can debate and put
on the side it's 2
700 tons of that stuff and the problem
is
the defense knows ministry of defense
they know ministry of interior they know
the ministry of economy knows
the prime minister knows the security
agency no
and if nobody knows then the justice
system already knows and there's a court
case in it
so everyone is aware of that threat and
there was excessive pressure
to keep them there six years from the
pressure from jose exported
pressure from who pressure
from the political entities and the
people covering those who try to
import ammonium nitrate into the country
under depleted
who was trying to import this is that a
matter of public knowledge and court
record
and the court records that is available
i don't have the name of the company but
the company that is importing should be
investigated and what was the purpose
and why that big amount of material and
then the second question
is why were they kept in one place why
not in a safe position away from the
port
which is a critical element in the
infrastructure knowing the threat that
they included
and why weren't they directly
re-exported
why were they impounded for six years
and no one was capable of taking action
this can only happen with excessive
political
pressure and intervention in the justice
system which means
people in the political establishment
are directly linked to this and that is
why a lot of big happens
and that is precisely my question who
are those people
is it known who are those people in the
political setup
that decided to keep that investigations
to do
yes the direct people responsible prime
minister
president minister of defense uh the
port directors those are the direct
people are responsible
for it who's exercising pressure on them
then that's what the investigation
should do
and the question is to the judges the
senior judges handling this case
they should have gotten to the bottom of
this instead of
letting that political pressure continue
and leaving that dangerous material
in the port for six years who control
which faction controls the ports in
beirut
everyone knows in lebanon that the port
and the airport are highly influenced by
hezbollah activists
and political pressure because they are
used and they
are intervened with on a regular basis
but there are other factions as well
that are all aligned but anything like
this no one has the leverage that
hezbollah has
so most probably it's hezbollah who can
exercise pressure of that size
in this critical port which imports 80
percent
of lebanon's imports in total including
most of its food
most of its medicines all of that has
been damaged lebanon's strategic
grain backup has been destroyed the
grain reserves
which include wheat for flour and all of
this
someone with massive power that can
[ __ ] an entire government
and all of it ministries can do that and
no one has that power except hezbollah
that must be raising some question marks
then for
that group and faction to answer for
then
definitely and not only them but the
political government that is supported
by them the current government
the current president of the republic
those are people who should be held
accountable
for a crime against humanity the total
destruction of a city
because of negligence the death of more
than a hundred people
and the hospitalization of more than
four thousand today the hospitals have
been calling
for in distress because their moors are
full
there are no places to put the dead
bodies in the hospitals of downtown
beirut
they're starting to move their bodies to
other hospitals around the country
this is mass murder committed by the
negligence and the political interests
of a few who are creating the political
power in this country and abusing its
people
all right it's been uh great to get your
thoughts and analysis on that thank you
so much for
uh make taking the time to come and talk
with us mark dalton